learners permit thursdays on my youtube
subscribe today la jolla thank you so
much we sold out some more shows down
there man we've hit them now in indy
baltimore we've hit them in cleveland in
la jolla thank you so much for your
support austin unfortunately has to be
rescheduled the club is not going to be
open in time and kansas city i can't
wait to get to your wonderful town i'll
be there january 20th through the 22nd
get your tickets for those dates and all
dates at ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com and ryan sickler on all your
social media uh dates the night pants
nation tour is going [ __ ] great i
can't thank you enough for your support
uh coming up next is la jolla what's
that december 15th through the 17th and
austin
january 6th through the 8th tickets
available ryan sickler.com
uh youtube listen this channel continues
to grow and grow and grow
and uh i can't thank you enough for that
either so i know you're watching please
subscribe
and uh the patreon is just
it's like i don't know it's like how do
you pick your favorite kid that damn
show has the wildest stories
and it's five bucks a month and yeah i
do know that's a lot of money for some
people absolutely i know that's a
utility bill i know it's a sell bill i
know that 60 bucks a year but if you
sign up for a year you'll save a little
bit of money you'll get over a month
free all right i'm doing everything i
can to keep call slow and keep bringing
you good [ __ ] cause y'all have not let
me down if you all know someone or you
have that story has to be heard please
submit it to honeydewpodcast gmail.com
hopefully we get to do an episode
together all right uh the website here
the honeydew podcast oh sorry
honeydewpodcast.com
and um merch is still all stocked up the
holidays are here man get your honeydew
merch for holidays makes a great gift
okay now you know what we do here we
highlight the lowlights these are the
stories behind the storytellers i'm very
excited to have this uh guest back
on the do ladies and gentlemen please
welcome back a lot of the gretty welcome
back to the honeydew lana yeah you got
it [ __ ] yeah clap yourself in not enough
people do
um all right first of all thank you for
coming back thank you you look fantastic
as always um people don't see your
cowboy boots but maybe we can get them
in in the picture i mean i could put it
put them up girl can i see them that's
nashville that's nashville um please
before we get into everything we're
gonna talk about today plug promote
everything you would like first and
foremost outreach through the arts um
the nonprofit ryan works on with me as
well
we've had a rough year but we've built
some amazing programs that are coming
out um so i definitely want to plug ada
ottarts.org is where you can go to find
out more about all the programs we're
doing and the kids we're serving and how
you can help contribute with time or
money and then of course you know santa
monica music center culver city music
center those are the two spots that i
own my family business for music lessons
instrument needs we've got you covered
podcast studios now all right let's talk
about that and we're about to open up
our live recording studio as well so if
whether you want to learn because you're
a novice or you're a professional you
need a space um that's where you can go
santa monicamusiccenter.com you can look
at both locations from that website and
then lastly
by the time this comes out i'll be
gearing up to campaign for
city council santa monica city council
so i'm on there now um
i was appointed but i'll be running my
campaign for election next november so
if you're in santa monica and you can
vote please vote for me if you're not
please move and register to vote
let me just get some [ __ ] yeah all right
so we have a little bit to talk about
here first of all
um
this blew me away the small world story
that happened after your first so i want
to say this also there's uh links on the
honeydew podcast uh website as well you
can go there to get anything to reach
out to santa monica music center
so we did uh we did the first episode
which if you don't know who lon is you
want to know go listen to that first
episode it actually is a really great
episode and after that some things start
popping off and then the community and
people are hearing this and that
and an article gets written
i mean is that what you call that yeah i
would i wouldn't call it i guess uh you
know whatever some trash gets thrown out
it blows across the street and
our neighbor here our neighbor this man
comes up and approaches you correct yep
and how long would you say after that
episode
probably like
i mean it had to have been
when did we do that one god
it's like a year after because i was
already on city council which is kind of
how it came
about i think i don't know if he listens
to your podcast or if it's because one
of the council members
article whatever so what what you
reference specifically in that podcast
that we're talking about is that uh what
happened to you was so seventh grade i
was twelve dosed right yeah
put acid in my drink um
i don't know that i named him but maybe
um anyways it's my experience it's my
information i um but and it led to a
bunch of [ __ ] oh yeah led to a bunch of
[ __ ] um for me in my childhood it was a
pivotal moment for me for sure was
trauma if you will um
but i guess it also was for him so when
that happened he never apologized or
never reached out to me as a matter of
fact i felt
the opposite in the encounters that i
had with him after that that maybe he
felt the victim somehow i don't really
know um
but
post that he's standing there
and i'm looking at this person look at
me and i'm like rushing out right
outside right outside in the garage and
he's using the space at the landlord who
we love so dearly
what a what a jab rents out over there
and he's like lana i think he said lana
fernandez which when anyone uses my
maiden name i'm like oh you know me from
high school or before
and then as i'm looking at him i realize
who it is and he's like it's me so he
wanted to schedule some time it was him
it was him it was the guy and i haven't
seen or talked about his next story or
family [ __ ] i mean he works like he's
an independent writer i think so he's he
uses that space
so
i could see it as i see look like
genuine like oh my gosh i want to have
this connection do you have time to sit
down
um you said that yes if we could make
time for each other and we still have to
um and has he ever said the word has he
still said the words i'm sorry no i
don't think he's had that opportunity
maybe that's what he wants to say he had
the opportunity right out front on the
sidewalk i think he was so
so whatever you know listen man well
again i don't know maybe his purpose is
to say what he experienced from it which
we'll find out but
um
yeah so and then afterwards it's crazy
it's so crazy crazy you tell that story
and then you come to work one day and
this dude's like a year or later man i'm
part of night pants nation i gotta tell
you
and i'm assuming it's either that or one
of the council members that knows him
yeah and they ran into each other and he
was trying to get a hold of me maybe he
heard it whatever i don't know maybe
someone heard it um
but anyways yeah so that spawned this
which would be take a lot of the lunch
[ __ ] and say you're sorry i'm
not getting my bringing my own dream i
said it yeah and bring your own goddamn
dream
hold on
so we talk about what you got to tell me
by the way
[Laughter]
i just hope he has a good sense of humor
because i do i mean that's his [ __ ]
problem yeah you're the one that got
dosed that's the you know what the crazy
thing is
was other people were involved in like
oh you know
that was traumatic i guess i guess he
had his whatever happened to him
afterwards there might have been some
trauma for him around it which i respect
and can acknowledge but that's a crazy
story it's a crazy story and i hope it
ends in you know some new relationship i
think we all grow up and become parents
30 years ago like i hope yeah i hope you
get full closure finally yeah
um
all right here's what i also do want to
well i don't we're not going to talk
about because i'm sure people are like
loaded yeah we're not talking about
uh politics here we're not talking about
the looting or whatever happened to us
we're not sitting here and the reason i
don't want to
first of all i don't give a [ __ ] what
other people think about what happened
to us yeah i don't give one [ __ ] what
anyone else thinks about what happened
to us yeah period okay because i am
proud of you i sat down there and
cleaned up glass and all that with you
and both of us instead of whining and
boo-hooing we lost just like everybody
maybe more than others and we just
[ __ ]
got up
and
started marching forward and not only
that growing and succeeding so i i'm
look i want to commend you because i'm
telling you
you got big dick energy you do if you
were a big labia if you were a dude your
dick be bigger i mean
and look you know what my daughter's mom
told you so we're sitting here both of
us sitting here a big dick energy girl
anyway i'm proud of you and let's talk
about what you did because
literally
picked ourselves up and you
let's talk about otta first and what we
what you did with that whole program i
mean almost like immediately after
because there was all the stuff
happening with all the racial tension
and the police um i mean nationally
so
here we are trying to
literally pick up pieces and build and i
thought oh my gosh what a great
opportunity
to create another class or course or way
for these kids that are in the diversion
program which is now called lead with
the santa monica police department
because i had a connection to santa
monica police i knew people that ran
that program
so i knew i could get access to these
kids in the neighborhood
and i thought there's no trade schools
you know people
this industry whether it be music
entertainment you know including
podcasting all of it is so mystified for
kids and they don't even know like how
do you how do you get to where you are
now like what were the steps taken so it
was a great way to teach kids how to run
pre-production post-production you know
teaching them the four-camera live
switch teaching them skills that they
could literally take and put on a resume
and go get a paying job for
but more importantly i thought the
dialogue that they could have
would really
be meaningful for the community for
themselves so you created a course a
class with you well it's your stuff but
i created a curriculum you created the
class yeah and the opportunity for these
people and myself because i i've come to
you and said i thank you for including
me in it because i really love it i've
enjoyed it
um
and
you're right because i as as a parent
especially now and and watching
and knowing what i paid for college and
watching these people
get just into an almost six-figure hole
that they're never gonna pay off coming
out so i then i question wow is college
really the right move i know i am the
generation of parents who they got their
high school diploma and went right into
the workforce maybe touched on college a
little bit but it was boom we were the
generation that was supposed to go to
college to further ourselves i think
this generation i agree like again
there's nothing wrong working at
starbucks little caesars whatever
nothing at all i think that's great for
you too but if you can get an early jump
on something that you have a passion for
and like you said whether it's
production because we've taught the kids
in here the cameras we've taught them
audio we've taught them live switching
we've taught them editing basic
production music how to pick your titles
graphics we've taught them everything
and we've done two courses now and how
to be a host how to speak how to be a
host and be a guest also you know so
um and to get out of your comfort zone
because these kids are interviewing the
[ __ ] police yeah fresh off of like we
still sleep sweeping up glass out right
now i'm still wondering where the [ __ ]
they were you know i'm like we're all
like y'all come here for the class huh
no problem getting here for the class
anyway i joke kinda
but um you're right you know if someone
just learns how to do cameras or editing
or whatever they can walk forward with a
real skill that they can take out into
the world and start making good money
early on and connections that could help
further them down the line because this
shit's not going anywhere no the
youtubes and not only podcasting but all
this create content creation's not going
anywhere
bigger and better real tangible skills
which is what i think we're missing like
those i mean when i was in high school
you learned how to change your oil and
we had rop programs where you left early
to work in a certain
um field or whatever so like literally
repairing wires setting up mics doing
post-production that's a job that is not
just the creative side of it it's like
that's a thing that you can learn and do
like we can teach anybody that and you
can do that job and make a living and
then maybe from there as you're in that
world surrounded by those people you
find your creative outlet but for some
people that is the creative piece of it
so i think what's hard is when you know
we can't just look at these kids doing
all this tick tock and creative content
blogging stuff i just hung out last
night with um a couple that was like how
long have you and your husband been
together i'm like oh we met in 2000 he's
like i was born in 2000.
and they're making more than us
you know content creating content on
tick-tock and blogging and instead of
you know poo-pooing it or laughing at it
it's like that's great but do you
actually know i think what's even more
valuable is if you know how to set up
your own stuff like if you could set it
up and produce it then you're more
valuable because if your content is gone
and no one likes it in a couple months
and it's just like a one-hit wonder you
can still go get a pretty well-paid job
with insurance doing the other stuff so
these kids you know
having a foot in the door in this
industry is a big deal who you know it
is so saturated so it almost makes it
more competitive in a way you got to be
like extra special to stand out well
with what i really loved it was a moment
where i just was like there it is
because at first you were like this
person's pockets pocket i go lana
everybody's got a [ __ ] face and then
there was like after like two months
somebody came up to the front of us
you're like she goes i want to do a
pocket shirt everybody's got a [ __ ]
podcast i was like
because i didn't even listen to podcasts
before and then i realized like
everybody has a podcast but
everybody's got an opinion everybody's
got something to say and everyone has a
crowd to listen to them and i respect
that um but these kids i wanted them to
learn skills so that whatever they
walked away with they they learned
something at the end of the day and we
were also providing a platform for the
police to
expose who they are as human beings
because here are kids who have had
negative interactions and positive
interactions with police and i think in
this program the positive has outweighed
the negative in our community so i
wanted to send a positive message
because the negative narrative was
already out there
and we had kind of cast this national
opinion on all police officers that
they're all bad and
i was friends with a lot of these guys
who grew up not wanting to be police
because of what they endured in their
communities and then deciding no that's
actually why i want to be be a police
officer and then you remember it started
turning into these cops for moving
um you know their shifts so that they
could come and be honest yeah they were
all coming in and also we interviewed uh
the chief of police who
what i was told this woman made history
so um she was the first i believe black
female
officer and then went all the way to the
ranks and was the first ever everything
every level all the way up to chief of
police it was so good that the current
chief of police during the [ __ ]
was out and she came back in to help out
i mean yeah and these kids got to sit
down and talk to that woman about you
know her life i wanted to come on here
just because i have so many questions
about you know the racism and sexism
because she told a story yeah about how
or they had said i don't know if i'm
allowed to say this but um the domestic
violence call she went on yeah she went
on a domestic violence call with a
female partner i believe and then her
backup showed up and the two guys waited
outside because they figured she would
get roughed up and [ __ ] up in there
and they'd come in and captain save a
hoe and make them look good and like see
y'all can't really do the job and
apparently she drug that [ __ ]
down the steps and then they said you
want us to call it in and she's like we
got it
yeah yeah no she's a badass and my dad's
a fan as you know oh yeah
he watched her take somebody down and
um yeah no i mean that was the whole
point like like let's look at people
as people and find out who they are and
these kids got to give their perspective
because for the longest we were hearing
um a community that has a 30 000 foot
view which i like to say it's like this
luxury of having this 30 000 foot view
um
the luxury to have space and time to
really think about a problem and come up
with a solution is a true luxury but
when you're in it in the [ __ ]
um there's a lot of value in that
because you have real life experience to
be applied to the situation and that's
how i see these kids like
they're living it and they're the next
generation let's let them lead the
conversation because i think they have
something to say which as we found out
was quite different from what some
people were saying they were like i
don't want to defund the police i'm in
this amazing i wouldn't be here today
learning how to podcast if it wasn't for
our
local police the santa monica pd and
this amazing lead program i wouldn't be
learning all these great things you know
officer so-and-so gave me my first pair
of jordans and
i got thanksgiving you know dinner
delivered to me by this officer so
we were just going through such a
negative time and everything was so
negative i just wanted an opportunity to
say there's really there's good people
out there in all fields and
if there's a way to shed some light on
that and teach some kids um a trade that
they can actually go get a job with
well then i feel like that's something
that's great some of them really
impressed me like took right to it some
of them were like i'm never going to be
in front of the camera cut two they were
like the best in front of the camera i
can't remember the one young girl's name
but she loved rogan and i was like you
listen to joe rogan she's like yeah
remember she was palsy and she wanted
that one cop to come in and she's like i
want to ask him why he never says hello
to me and i go are you serious she's
like yup and she put them in there she
goes how come you never say hi to me he
was like oh
yeah
i was like look at her in there it was
awesome and then you know because of
mark wahlberg had stepped in
and created a bunch of connections
dwayne who started here
and then that connection between mark
who introduced me to talitha which
connected me to william morris
entertainment he got to be able to have
a dialogue and a possible mentorship
with kevin shiver so i mean none of that
would have happened had all those
negative things right not happen so
it's just you know well then we also
um well again you also i keep saying we
cause i feel so like i'm excited to be a
part of it so i apologize i don't want
to take any credit from you but you
created also
now that was for at-risk youth in santa
monica with the police department you
also have a program through otta as well
for the culver city high school kids and
i got to teach uh the curriculum to the
culver city high school kids and they
were they were great too yeah different
group of kids um they were already
taking some classes in like media and
entertainment so
that was just it was wonderful to have
them in the room and now they want to
make it a full-on extension part of
their school i think most schools are
leaning towards project-based
trade-based like teach putting kids in
front of the action and actually having
them do it yeah i mean look i think it
should be a class in high school now
yeah everyone's doing it at that age
already you're starting them quicker you
can learn this stuff and why wouldn't
you're teaching all the other [ __ ] those
those av kids would be all over this
[ __ ] remember that kid the dork that
wheeled the cart to class well i'm older
than you that kid would be like i got
your [ __ ] cameras and [ __ ] don't
worry no exactly yeah that's the kids
you should hang out with i'm that's
where i [ __ ] up hung out with all the
jocks instead of the nerd i know i think
about the nylon coding and everything
else
you're what
well i never else you got five huh
yeah
dungeons and dragons
god damn who's a loser now i had to be
all juco i don't pay [ __ ] i think about
that all the time and that's what i want
to share with kids is experience you
know and no matter what we share there's
always going to be they have to figure
it out themselves but i mean even during
this process once becoming on city
council i realized we have a whole
studio a block away from here tv studio
that that's what i'm saying why can't
that be added to votech that's what we
called it back in the day where you
don't work on a car or home x sort of
classes chef cooking all this like they
do they did a small program but this is
gonna be different no no for the for the
actual
studio where we had city tv when these
have aerobics classes a cooking class i
mean
the city had put tons of money and it's
just sitting there because of covid so
the idea is to have
the kids in this program be able to
learn how to work the big camera rigs
and everything that goes into putting a
show together and
hopefully having them take over the
communications for the city because how
cool would it be if the next generation
is out there interviewing citizens
talking to policymakers
um
creating content about our city
from the next generation who literally
in a few years could be up on the
diocese you know so
that's i want to make it i want to
unmystify the industry and opportunities
for kids to stand up and be leaders like
listen i mean
i wasn't that kid that was pushing the
card
i definitely wasn't i was definitely
going you know getting off campus
whenever i could or whatever but that
doesn't mean that you can't be afforded
opportunities like we got to look at the
glass half full and and who people are
and not what they aren't the holidays
are right around the corner if you want
help prepping for your parties and
family get-togethers all while
supporting a more sustainable local food
system check out imperfect foods
imperfect foods is a grocery delivery
service offering an entire line of
sustainable groceries that taste
delicious and reduce waste plus your
order will arrive on the same day
each week on average and perfect foods
customers save six to eight pounds of
food from lesser outcomes with every
order and unlike these other on-demand
delivery companies imperfect delivers
weekly by neighborhood it's a unique
model that produces 25 to 75 percent
fewer emissions than individual trips to
the grocery store plus say goodbye to
packaging guilt and perfect foods is the
only national grocery delivery company
that makes it easy to return your
packaging after every order they sent me
some food i i made i can tell you how
many meals i had stuffed peppers okay i
had uh scrambled eggs came with bacon
it's delicious i'm telling you other
people have already you guys have
already hit me up tell me how you used
it before and used it when you were in
college i think it's a great idea right
now imperfect foods is offering my
listeners 20 off your first four orders
when you go to imperfectfoods.com
and use the promo code honeydew again 20
off your first four orders that's up to
an 80 value at imperfectfoods.com
when you use the promo code honeydew
imperfectfoods.com and use code honeydew
athletic greens is a product i love i
take it every day and honestly i don't
eat well i don't eat well all the time i
say i don't have time for it i'm running
whatever and you know athletic greens
takes care of me so what is this stuff
right with one delicious scoop of
athletic greens you're absorbing 75 high
quality vitamins minerals whole food
source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to help you start your day
right this special blend of ingredients
supports your gut health your nervous
system your immune system your energy
recovery focused and aging all the
things contains oh wait all the things
contains less than one gram of sugar
there's no gmos no nasty chemicals or
artificial anything while still tasting
good it costs you less than three
dollars a day you're investing in your
health and it's cheaper than your cold
brew habit all right right now it's time
to reclaim your health and arm your
immune system with convenient daily
nutrition especially heading into the
flu and cold season it's just one scoop
and a cup of water every day that's it
it's easy no need for a million
different pills and supplements to look
out for your health to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you a
free
one year supply of immune supporting
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase all you have to
do is visit athleticgreens.com
honeydew again that is
athleticgreens.com
honeydew to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance the holidays and
new year are right around the corner
help your loved ones get closer to
achieving their health and wellness
goals with an everly well at-home lab
test everly well offers affordable
at-home lab tests that give you trusted
physician-reviewed results choose from
tests including food sensitivity
metabolism sleep and stress thyroid and
so much more here's how it works everly
well ships your test straight to your
door with everything needed for a sample
collection you return the test to a clia
certified lab with a prepaid shipping
label then your physician reviewed
results and insights are sent to your
device in just days over a million
people have trusted everly well with
their at-home lab testing your boy too
right here has they sent me one um i
tested for food sensitivity you just
little finger prick boom boom drop it on
the paper off it goes and like they said
right to your phone in days it was
pretty awesome i found out that i'm
sensitive to ginger how about that who
knew this holiday give more of what
matters with an everly well at-home lab
test for our listeners everly wells
offering a special discount of 20 off
and at home lab test at everlywell.com
honeydew that's everlywell.com honeydew
for 20 off your at home lab test
everlywell.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do
it's so funny like during this whole
process after i was on the show this
guy because now i get appointed to city
council yeah so now you google me that's
the only thing literally
nothing wrecked on the [ __ ] sidewalk
right to city councilwoman having to
have people deliver create
outreach to the arts for uh
a non-profit for the two new programs
and then become an la city excuse me
santa monica city council yeah not l.a
um
and which was crazy because people used
to joke around all the time like oh
you're mini mayor of santa monica
because i knew everybody and they'd call
me if they needed to know something um
or how to do something in santa monica
and then it was like you should be on
city council and i was like
i don't have time it's not the right
time and i was literally riding my
exercise bike i'll put a plug in for
peloton in case i want to send me
anything
my peloton or as louis likes to say my
peloton
and i have all these mel robins like
inspirational quotes and one of my
favorites is um start before you're
ready because nothing beats experience
and i thought you know what i'm never
gonna be ready i mean i thought i was
ready to have kids at a certain age and
their therapy bills will prove that i
wasn't but um but no i mean so i just
said you know what i'm just gonna do it
and then immediately like when it was
all happening because it was an
appointment process i was up against
like 33 other people or something but
it's a little different not a full-on
election but they're still like some
campaigning going on and then the minute
it actually happened it was so great and
then i got up there and i had to make a
vote right away but that night when i
went to bed i had a full-on panic attack
because i realized
my friends were texting me like people
were taking to social media that never
met me before saying mean things and i
was like oh i told you i was like i
don't know if i can do this like people
are read the comments about my life lana
you'll feel better about yourself
people are just so it's so crazy to me
that
like the minute somebody's up on a and
i'm not even like it's not like i'm
making money or anything like we get
paid fifteen thousand dollars you can't
get over there and we get a parking pass
though that's the key to this fifteen
thousand dollars and it's a parking job
and a parking ban that parking passes my
husband's always like show them how we
do it baby in the mall oh it didn't work
it's only all weekend
it's sunday from 12 to three but you can
park where i would [ __ ] you
uh no but i mean
that
that whole like experience of seeing how
people who maybe even met you and worked
with you in some like pta group and then
they take to some it takes to the who's
this [ __ ] think she is yes i know but
i'm like if you know some and these are
the people that diligently read all the
i haven't seen you what i mean and i've
been to 875 meetings and are you on a
board or a commission have you done
anything or do you just sit there behind
your computer and write things on social
media
and they know everything and how it
should be done and nobody everybody on
there is doing the wrong thing and you
don't know how to do it i'm like well
then get up here and do it but i mean
for for them to wait for the perfect
opportunity i want to do it
i just want to tell you how to do it and
how you're doing it right now you're
doing it wrong and [ __ ] it up but i
don't want to do it but i do know how to
okay
i had some lady come up to me where i'm
i got the great opportunity to announce
santa claus and do the tree lighting
which for me was a little bit like i
don't think the mayor realized when she
let me do it how much it meant because
growing up as a kid my dad used to play
on the stages there and we would see
santa we'd have to wait in line and it's
funny because my dad was a musician we
we didn't he wasn't like we got to go
first it was like yeah we'll let
everybody else go first and sometimes
i'd miss the opportunity i'd like have
all this anxiety like god damn it
there's 60 kids in line i might not meet
santa and they would do their annual
tree lighting and i got to go on stage
and read the last line that introduced
santa who lights the tree but right when
i get down this woman who i've known
whose kids have taken lessons and gotten
scholarships from me he's like you know
you got to do this and nobody knows what
you're doing because you're not saying
and you should do this and you should do
that and if you don't do this this way
that way and i can't help myself but i
was like why don't you do it i don't
have to do [ __ ] lady like
don't talk to me like that and come up
to me and just start telling me how i
should and hi how are you nice to meet
you nice to see you it's just crazy how
people feel like it's an open invitation
the [ __ ] on to [ __ ] on you yeah and like
what does that do
all the people that complain about our
sitting are so angry and they're so
certain that there's this conspiracy
theory going around that the entire
staff and everybody is all working
together to like
diabolically
take the city down i guess i don't know
i'm like why do you live here then like
if it sucks that much like
i don't get it or why aren't you a part
of this solution like it's so easy to
point out the problem and maybe say hi
what the solution could be but to
actually come up with the solution and
then
do the work towards making it right and
figuring out along the way ah that
wasn't the solution but maybe this is
and if we tweak it that way
certain people break you down and other
people break you down and then help
build you up and that's what the ru
that's what hey look i i see a better
way to do this great would you like to
help yes i would yeah that's i love
those people welcome them all day long
but it's the people who don't and then
you realize there's people who have
ulterior motives and you start getting
into all that stuff when i get into
politics i realize i'm not a politician
and so that might be the demise of my
campaign next year because people are
like well you got to do this because if
you don't then this person's going to
get and then that's going to mess up i'm
like but it's not right to do that and
they're like but if you don't do it then
this person i'm like well but it's not
right i got to be able to go to sleep at
night so i don't want to check off a box
of a group of people and say oh i voted
this way because whatever you guys
always say how to vote i'm always going
to vote that way it's like well i don't
know
because i have a different perspective
and experience in life and clearly it
was valued enough to get where i'm at
now and if i get elected then that means
that there's enough people that agree
with that and i think everybody has
value the the
ivy league lawyers that are up there to
the working moms i mean i'll just say
this though i'm the one that still is
running payroll and actually owns a
small business so
i think my voice has a lot of value now
there's times in the city you are in the
city yeah and i was born and raised here
so i have historical perspective as a
working-class person living in a
rent-controlled apartment building you
all lived in the walton house
i mean i mean i've got perspective for
sure so and i'm raising kids here and my
trajectory is not my goal is not to be
you know at the state or whatever level
my goal is just to serve my community so
it's not like i'm doing this to
get to the next step it's it's truly
just to serve the community and so my
kids
can get dropped off at the promenade
without having to carry
a weapon in their pocket now um
but no i mean that's
that's my goal and i'm so excited to be
able to like help on a bigger scale and
bring in the kids that i work with
that's that's really what i want to do
like look nobody thought i was going to
be up here including myself and i am and
i it reminded me of michelle michelle
obama when i went and listened to her
book reading i'll never forget when she
said
she i'm paraphrasing but she was like
basically her first few weeks
being there as first lady she thought oh
my god there's all these smart people in
the room like i'm not the smartest and
the fraud and then cut to like a year
later like i might be the smartest
person that's
right so figure it out logic and
pragmatic approach i mean
that's valuable to me so
i just try to bring that approach i try
not to be embarrassed i raise my hand i
ask you'll see me on the dice be like do
we always have to speak like we're in a
shakespeare play
if you got to put up a powerpoint to
explain that ordinance um maybe we
should be reducing it down to three
sentences so everybody can understand it
so i hope to bring that part to city
council so people see like oh like i'm
translating it for the people it's
unlike my powerpoint
there's somebody doing that right now
like you know i do powerpoints lana
that's what i do
someone's gonna hear this listen to this
like what did that guy write out of the
two hours we talked about
and her dad played intros to titty bars
and now i can't do my powerpoints this
[ __ ] bit
everyone picks out the most negative
things and look i like to laugh and make
fun
i mean
lou and i begging our kids so hard we're
like not sure if it's even right but we
laugh we laugh at each other we laugh at
ourselves and yeah that's okay but to
just be mean
like just to be mean is like really i
don't get it what's what do you what do
you get out of that like the people that
take time to comment
i'm not talking about your podcast but
you were saying people say plenty of
them but why are you gonna listen then
and then take the time to go on my
account and that's why when they say
like your laugh ruins every podcast i'm
like thanks for listening
thanks for listening all of them it's on
top you can get it as a ringtone now
you just leave 10 voicemails with your
laptop so let me ask you this you go
from being business destroyed to not
only building yourself back up but
building your community back up which is
unfucking believable yeah um becoming a
santa monica city councilwoman
and um or is it person council member
member okay yeah outside counseling
what are you
i want to highlight low light so right
now what are you most proud of and i
want a personal
like in my perspective right now you
could look back in a year and a half ago
and tell that
us down there sweeping that [ __ ]
glass up like hey
what are you most proud of
that we're still here i know that's so
basic but i really thought at that
moment so many businesses that are yeah
like that was and then you know what i
went through after that with the lease
negotiation so
i mean he showed up that day and was
like how are you going to pay for my
rent i was like
okay so the landlord shows up and tell
us about that conversation he literally
is walking around to see what happens
and he says how are you going to pay my
rent now
and i was like watch out for that glass
didn't he call you little girl oh many
times and all the negotiations like he
would wait for my dad to do meetings
even though and he called you little oh
yeah a little girl my favorite one was
um
when you uh you told him you brought
your feelings to a business oh yeah tell
me so
i was actually ready to give him a
bigger check than he ended up getting i
ended up reducing it because
you know i just wanted to make i wanted
to move on everybody was doing the whole
like not paying rent i was never doing
that i was giving more than i had to and
just no one knew like am i gonna owe all
this am i not i mean people are still
sitting in that predicament so
i just kind of wanted to close that
chapter even though people said well
you're just wait i was like i just want
to move on and know a little bit more
about the future and in order to do that
i got to close this so i had written out
the check and he comes in there first of
all he doesn't want to just talk to me
he wants my dad in there which is always
funny to me because my dad's either
falling asleep after meeting or he'll
say
the most inappropriate [ __ ] yeah
he just i won't even say what he says
because someone will pick that up but
anyways
um and he'd see my dad's looking at me
like i don't know ask her but he had
brought um his broker who was great who
all i could see was his eyes during the
whole meeting but at some point i mean
he's he's we were just about to give him
the check and he goes i just want to say
something
and he went on to say
you chose to pay your employees before
me you chose to take care of all your
employees and probably your vendors but
you paid your employees before me and
that's horrible you need to respect me
i'm the landlord and you wouldn't be
here if it wasn't for me and blah blah
he went into this whole like die tribe
about how horrible of a person i was and
ultimately like you know how dare you
yeah how dare i take care of my
employees and i was like if i had to do
it again that's exactly how i do it
didn't pay myself paid my employees and
they're still here they didn't have to
you know struggle to eat or whatever
but he didn't get that concept but i was
like listen it's unfortunate thank you
for sharing
that you brought all your feelings about
me and how i handled everything to this
meeting so
let me just take this check back
yeah and look at your broker who said
that you know we could possibly
negotiate differently and then it was
like uh the broker was like uh uh maybe
you should just accept and i was like
boy you brought your feelings into your
business i'm gonna get my feelings
involved a little bit your feelings you
brought them into business i was like
listen for all the things you've said to
me and done to me
i've never once taken that into account
because the business transaction is
separate like i may not like you as a
person or think all these things about
you but yeah but
this is a business transaction and this
is who i'm doing business with right now
and that's what it is so but
unfortunately he let me know what he
felt about me and i was like good to
know good to know wasn't some of the one
that signs the check let me just take
that back so i mean we're not in the
best situation but we're here he just
rolled through the other day with
bankers
i don't know if it's like a thing to
make me nervous he's like these are my
bankers i'm like okay
so does he know your uh city council
yeah he does announce he's probably
listen to this that's fine
let him listen i think you know
the reality what scares you the most i
think what scares me the most is
not succeeding at this like dream that i
have to create what i've actually been
you're doing manifesting and doing
so it scares me that i won't keep taking
those steps because as silly as it
sounds because i'll look back and go oh
[ __ ] i did do it it's like and what do i
tell you all the time
just [ __ ] do it just do it i know
don't wait just do it i know and that
was my biggest thing because i think i
procrastinated a lot procrastinated a
lot um
i just wasn't i it's a big um what do
you call it um imposter syndrome i've
always had that like i don't deserve to
be in this room or around these people
or
i want to create this thing but it'll
never really look like that because
that's meant for these type of people
and i think that's a product of like
growing up with
nothing or less you know what i mean um
and so i just constantly told myself
that story and then honestly i read a
couple good books
um
i love james clear atomic habits i read
that book for the third time and shared
it with the kids during the podcast and
it's just making those small changes
to make yourself one percent better
every day um
and mel robbins all those all those
inspirational books but they took to me
during that time because i thought okay
what's my choice it's either do nothing
like tim's chat or she
tim's tim's mom
no
no it's not that's funny though i don't
even think about that tony tony
for melanie no just mel mel robbins
she's like a big she's a big speaker and
actually she talks about how you know
she was bankrupt going bankrupt just a
few years ago and you start to go like
well damn if somebody like that could be
standing right here if somebody like
that has imposter syndrome and one of
the cheesiest things she has is high
five habit challenge that i've been
doing and i want my kids to do it trying
to get them to do it is high-fiving
yourself in the mirror it sounds so
stupid and you feel so ridiculous doing
it
but it's proven scientifically that like
you can't think negative thoughts about
yourself when you do it i just broke the
[ __ ] mirror
all the time your hand broke your
[ __ ] mirror
oh wow god damn it
lana's [ __ ] i got handprints
everywhere no but i just started to say
you know what i'm just gonna do it and
even if my even if the goal is here and
i just start and i get to there that's
the first step and then that's all it
takes it's like when you say you don't
want to exercise you're like i'll just
go for a five minute walk it turns into
a three mile jog i mean it was just
taking the first step and doing it and
not judging myself being kind to myself
and being like you know what you could
have not done anything
but you're doing it and we work for
ourselves and i forget people remind me
of this is my family business inside
your family business yes and i mean
that's a
to not have to depend on someone else to
create the structure and the entity that
feeds your kids is
a big scary deal so i have to remind
myself that i've been doing that for a
really long time and i've figured it out
successfully and what does success mean
like
is it the big house or this or that no
it's being able to know that i make my
own hours
it doesn't feel like that sometimes it
feels like you're you know tied to do
certain things but they're choices like
no one's i'm not doing anything for
someone else i'm doing them for me
um and in terms of being like a city
council member there's times where you
feel like oh my gosh i got to do this i
got to do that but it's part of serving
the
community which serves my family too so
i think
my biggest fear would be not to take
those steps and my biggest
accomplishment is having
trusted in and valuing the baby steps
because the baby steps leads to the big
things amen to that that's the truth so
um
what's next
there's so many things like here's the
thing you love to take care of so many
people i always worry about you because
you don't really sleep yeah you don't i
mean i don't want to say you don't take
care of yourself because you definitely
take care of yourself you eat well you
exercise you do all the right things
but whatever everybody
stopped um but
i i get
you know if it fails everything goes
away for you i think about that
and helping other people so you lose
all of your passions so what is next
then
well on that note what i've
this is another cheesy cliche thing but
i truly live by and i think i've always
felt this way is your net worth is your
network
and i have created a network of people
and it's shifted because
when you're in a negative cyclone like
you suck in all the negative people and
events like you you it becomes a pattern
like one negative thing after the other
i mean usually kind of you stub your toe
in the morning you forget your keys you
spill your coffee and then it's just
like a [ __ ] show for the rest of the day
unless you can stop yourself and be like
all right restart and i think i did a
restart on myself started being more
positive to myself
which in turn led to people more
positive people being around me
and then that just sort of grew and grew
and grew and it's all that like what you
put out into the universe which i was
raised that way but for the longest i
ran away from that because i was like
all that positive manifestation is not
paying my cell phone bill or my rent
unfortunately i tried it i tried to call
up the landlord be like listen i'm just
putting [ __ ] out there buddy um
but i just saw the secret and uh i'm
wondering if i could hold off on that
money for three months oh my god i mean
that's i kept you know
practicality was like that's not gonna
work so but what does work is
when you're writing things down and
manifesting it's not that the act of
writing it down it's that you're
thinking about it and if you keep
thinking about it and repeating it over
and over all of a sudden something
that's connected to that thought is the
idea is the phone call with the person
who's like oh my god let me have you
connect to this person i mean if i were
to say just from you just from what
happened just from a few contacts the
outer rings of those
seven degrees of separation is crazy
like the amount of people that i've met
that i've kept in my life i really value
relationships with people i just it's my
oxygen and so
when you when you say like what happens
when it all goes away i panic about that
and sometimes it keeps me from
trying to attain the dream of like
owning a home again because i think
well i don't have any you know job
security in that sense but who does
so
i do know though what i do have is an
amazing group of people and i truly feel
like i've seen it happen when we got
looted we had people delivering food to
our house for over a month and to my
staff here i mean it's crazy my daughter
got sick people come and bring things
and offer to drive and do this and that
just reminding me that i'm always going
to have the things my mom taught me to
worry about are you safe are you loved
are you housed are you clothed like
those are very primal basic things and
some people don't have those and so i
know that with my network around me i'll
never not have those things and that's a
luxury because that's that's my
financial safety net to that allows me
to be creative because i know i'll have
those fundamental things and i've lived
with the bear bear bare bones basics i
mean we had wick checks and i had to put
my kids in swim diapers when i couldn't
afford diapers and i mean we i've lived
it i've lived both of it the highs and
the lows i know what it's like to carry
a 2 000 person live in a nice house with
a waterfall in the back and i know what
it's nice what it's like to have four
kids stuffed in a bedroom wondering when
you're gonna take your kid out of those
swim diapers
and eating little caesars pizza all the
time cause it's five dollars like
so to me i'm like i think that's the
value of like the kids we work with it's
like i've been in the gym of life
i've had the heaviest weights put on
there so i've lifted in the gym i've
sprinted i've trained so when the the
you know the race of life has started
i'm like oh i've trained for this i've
seen this i've been knocked down i know
how to get back up i've i know the the
curves on this track so i don't feel as
afraid as maybe somebody who doesn't
have all that experience and has taken
the elevator their whole life and always
had doors open for them given the ride
yeah never had to try the different keys
to get in the door breaking through the
window or just [ __ ] locked out in the
goddamn cold punch somebody in the face
to get in that's fine
cooler weather makes it easier to miss
signs of dehydration like overheating or
perspiration which means it's even more
important to keep your body properly
hydrated one stick of liquid iv in 16
ounces of water hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water alone you know we
love liquid iv i take that every day
take it to the gym throw it in my water
bottle boom i'm hydrating i'm taking it
on my walks we keep it here at the
studio people grabbing them in on the
way out putting them in the coffee mugs
right now liquid iv is on a mission to
change the world the company is donating
4 million servings in response to kova
19 products are being donated to
hospitals first responders food banks
veterans and active military grab your
favorite liquid iv flavors nationwide at
walmart or you can get 25 off when you
go to liquidive.com and use the code
honeydew at checkout that's 25 off of
anything you order when you get better
hydration today using the promo code
honeydew at
liquidive.com it's funny there's all
these gimmicks that promise a great
night's sleep and i don't care what kind
of toppers there are or how heavy a
blanket may be it's lipstick on a pig if
you are sleeping on a terrible mattress
your sleep's going to be terrible it's
that simple that's why i recommend
sleeping on a purple mattress that's
because only purple mattresses have the
gel flex grid it's a super stretchy
ultra squishy material that adapts and
flexes around pressure points and
doesn't retain heat unlike memory foam
which remembers everything thanks to the
gel flex grid purple mattresses bounce
back as you move and shift you will
never have that i'm stuck feeling people
get with memory foam
officially we all have mirror all right
sent me a mattress kirsten's got a
purple mattress and he's sleeping on a
purple mattress and his exact words were
i recommend it and so do i they're a
great mattress if you're looking for a
mattress right now you're in the market
for one purple mattress is the way to go
try your purple mattress risk free with
free shipping and returns and financing
is available too getting a great night's
sleep starts with having a great
mattress get a purple mattress go to
purple.com honeydew and use code
honeydew for a limited time you can get
10 off any order of 200 or more that's
purple.com honeydew code honeydew for 10
off any order of 200 or more again
purple.com honeydew promo code honeydew
terms apply hey fellas this episode of
the honeydew is brought to you by our
favorite producers of ball trimmers
manscape the global leaders in below the
waste grooming are leaving 2021 with new
product clean yourself into the new year
with their ultra premium body wash also
special offer alert use the code
honeydew for 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com four million men
already trust manscape it's time to join
them 2022 is on its way and the last
thing you want is to be the guy with
pubes getting in your way of making this
year your best yet manscape engineered
the ultimate groin and body trimmer by
focusing on intelligent functionality
and an incredibly comfortable grooming
experience their fourth generation
trimmer features a cutting edge ceramic
blade to reduce grooming accidents
thanks to their advanced skin safe
technology and it's even waterproof so
use the code honeydew for 20 off and
free shipping at manscape.com i'm all in
on confidence and smelling good this
year join me with manscape get 20 off
and free shipping with the code honeydew
at manscape.com that's 20
off and free shipping at manscape.com
and use code honeydew happy new year to
your balls now let's get back to the do
as far as mentally um
especially being
cynical and a comedian and everything
it's uh it's easier to go the negative
yeah you know the this is that that it
is harder to go with the positive
thoughts so i um well you know i do that
five-minute journal i do it every day
i'm on like my fourth or fifth one
and it changed my mindset every day i
wake up i'm grateful for
you know and um
you know i always start with my health
everyone is my health and my daughter's
health what what do you have if you
don't have that yeah that to me is rich
you know i'm not in and out of a
hospital right now i did i was doing
that in 2016 and i was in and out of
hospitals for six seven months you know
all that [ __ ] so i'm so glad and i
put myself on a five to five year plan
it might get to six but that's fine but
i've exceeded what i wanted to do in
that five years and i had a plan
um that goes all the way up to including
getting a dog and all this [ __ ] like i
wrote it out so that i could you know go
for it and that's what i did i even
remember about the money part which is
crazy
because in the most untraditional way i
attained that money part within 1 367
it's crazy like how
you know i just started doing other
things like i'm you know creating spaces
and events and booking djs and that once
events started opening back up that
started happening and then
that led to meeting more people so that
was a source of income and something i
wanted to do
coupled with like other things so yes
the store maybe was not in a position
where to afford me any you know because
i couldn't see that like well i'm gonna
pay myself more we can't afford this but
it came in other ways and i also got
opportunities to be a part of things
that didn't end up costing me money to
be a part of you know what i mean so i
look at that as
as income one of the biggest things that
i took away with is the um
million dollar morning from mel robbins
which is you put your f and i have to
tell you i've been really bad about it
lately and i can tell the difference
i've dm'd you a few times and tagged you
but no she
it's such a simple thing but if you just
put your phone to charge not i use my
phone as my alarm so if you can just use
an alarm clock it's better
but if you can't you put it far away
from you and then like in a bathroom or
whatever and you just use the alarm to
wake up now if you can't do that which
i've been really good about it is you
let it wake you up but you do not look
at instagram facebook emails text
messages who called you nothing you
don't not look at your phone you just
shut off the alarm for at least 30
minutes in those first 30 minutes and
for me i try to do an hour you wake up i
make my coffee
um i'll do a 10-minute meditation i'll
use the comm app like that's what i like
to use whatever and then i'll read
whatever book i'm reading at the time
and i'll do a workout if i can and if
you can only do 30 minutes that's fine
but it's so true like if you're laying
in bed she's like do you think oprah's
laying in bed looking at people's
instagrams i mean
whether they're positive things or you
opened an email that's a great new
project you've now soaked up like the
first part of your day like already
thinking about all these projects you
have to do and you don't have time to
like clear your mind and be creative she
goes into this part about like while
she's brushing her teeth is when she
lets just all the ideas flow that's for
whether you're a creative or not it
could be whatever it is that's on your
mind i i use a notes thing and i think
of poetic things and crazy funny
episodes for
possibly future things i want to do and
i just speak into my notes it i i ended
up speaking this whole thing that became
a talk at my mom's spiritual center
about riding the waves of of life and
uncertainty but i just speak these
things out now but if i wake up and i'm
on my instagram and i'm on my facebook
and all that next thing you know i'm in
a dark hole following people i don't
know i'm watching somebody's cat video
about skippity paps
yeah tiny bakers that was a good way to
go down a hole um but i start looking at
things that i that have nothing to do
with me that's not serving me they're
pointless
and it robs you of your day and it sets
you up scientifically like i just think
it sets your mind up and your your head
space so different when i
i got to 30 minutes easily it's a full
hour now in the morning of not looking
at it and it feels great because i feel
like i've accomplished i read i did a
meditation i worked out for 30 minutes
or whatever and
now i can look at those things you know
and
be a bit distracted but try to time
myself on it that was that was a big
that was a big shift for me because i
was getting sucked into like
it's easy to get sucked into like oh
look at what everybody else is doing i
haven't arrived or when we were coming
up with all the ideas of what to do and
you were like and i'm like oh no someone
else is already doing it like better
that's it's easy to be like oh forget it
then i'm not gonna do it but
i was already had set my morning up with
nope today i'm making these phone calls
you know i'm putting these mics in the
studio to make this happen like you just
keep moving forward
i mean i've spent
money that i didn't think i had
to make something work like the podcast
studio in culver city
and it didn't take off right away but
we're using it studios
and it sat there for a couple months but
now we've got people creating content in
there
um same thing with the live recording
studio
really easy to just be like well i don't
have the money to do that but figuring
it out taking a zero percent credit card
loan and making that choice to say i
could do that or i could build it
and then
have a space to do the program and not
have to rely on other people so what
surprised you the most
that i made it to this point honestly
i'd surprised me the most that i've made
these connections like
that whole thing when everybody saw the
gofundme and all that we got some
attention and then you were bringing
people in and that was attention by like
you know celebrity people whatever
and i just thought like oh that'll come
and go i there was a there was a piece
of me that was like this is the 10
seconds of fame around this thing um and
then a little bit of anxiety and fear
like oh no i need you know i need to
keep this going so people know what
we're doing here
but surprised me the most is that
that's happened like it's still people
are still saying wow you've been doing
this for a long time like we love that
your store is such a community store we
didn't realize that outreach through the
arts was serving this many kids in these
different programs because i never
really had the time to go out and do all
the promotion for it and i want to just
do the work
um well that's what the mom and pop
shops that you know during this virus
that's still going on they've wanted to
save the targets and the walmarts and
all that right and they've left the mom
and pop shops go to this wayside so even
before
you had no support from these people
it's people like you who are out there
word of mouth like bring your kids here
try and do this try and do this so
um to be able to have a larger platform
to get the word out i think is a really
great thing too and also to raise
awareness because like you said people
like i didn't know you were even doing
all this like yes the biggest surprise
has actually been how many of these
people who are super successful in what
they do want to come out and help i mean
like want to fly out for a day to work
with the kids want to give their time i
mean i have an amazing producer who's
just created a whole curriculum that he
wants to do on just teaching kids how to
produce you've given all your a definite
day up to teach these kids i mean i'm
surprised i love it i'm learning how to
receive because i
give and it feels uncomfortable to
receive and women in general like we say
sorry all the time like sorry or like
someone compliments you and they're
you're like oh it was on sale or
you know someone would be like oh you
look great i'm like i don't know
i just sharp
i love your eyelashes i have a
hemorrhoid like you always have to
discount yourself
but i'm learning how to just be like
thank you like you know and let people
participate and not feel like oh they're
gonna come and participate and i'm not
this big glamorous uh nonprofit that's
doing it this way but we're doing the
work so they come in here and they're
like oh my god you might not have a
shiny brochure but who needs one when
you're doing this amazing work so
i mean we've collected so many people
who have given of their time well good
people do want to help yeah they really
do and and that's who you want you want
the good ones they don't mind
like for me i've said before like i wish
i had a you in my life when i was those
kids age you know like oh my god someone
that's shown me something and with a
sense of purpose and direction and
everything you know i'm just
aimlessly bouncing around doing what i
think
is best for me and then of course i
really believe
um
especially with like the death of my
father at 16 and my mom not being around
i think that stunted me
um
10 years minimum a decade in life and i
went and got a a master's degree in the
school of like you said the school
[ __ ] hard knocks
but
learning how to do anything financially
or how to do this i didn't know any
[ __ ] thing yeah i never leased
anything didn't have a credit card
didn't and so i'm doing laundry like i'm
just learning everything you know once
the internet came around i was like who
the [ __ ] needs parents but
but it was it was rough up till 96 you
know what i'm saying rough till nine
seconds oh my god no but that's true i
mean like
in some ways our generation has become
less what we think is less not our
generation i'm sorry the next generation
less resourceful in a way because
information is so at their fingertips
but actually i watch it as a mom of a
teenager like it's their version of
being resourceful you know and we put
that there we're sitting there going in
my day one ain't your day anymore
[ __ ] don't get an inspiration
it's still your day p.s
i mean it's still your day you're still
here just let's go with the time you
know what i mean encyclopedia
you all don't know [ __ ] about the dewey
decimal system
talk to me like that oh my god my my
daughter's friend had this 13 challenges
celebration and i was like what is that
and apparently they had them she had
their kids do certain things and then
they celebrated it and one of the things
was dropping them off in like downtown
l.a and then they had to figure out how
to get home and i'm older the kids like
they were twelve or thirteen yeah yeah
that's great though i don't know about
that not downtown that's great i think
it's a great i mean we were missing that
like
kids you know we're missing those kids
i could be missing those kids sorry
we're looking for these children we
dropped off today they're 12 and 13. i
mean tent city okay we'll check this
what's dead city it sounds nice oh me
and be in there like they're camping
i got baked beans mom
i mean i just think that there's some
things like kids wouldn't be able to
figure out how to get anywhere even
myself without maps i mean i use maps
sometimes to get home from places i
already know how to get home but see i
use it because i want to know the
fastest way to get home i don't use it
because i don't know how to [ __ ] get
home i want to avoid the [ __ ] traffic
my kids love it on soccer tournament
days
don't be following me on the freeway but
i like to reduce the time so we take i
said it says 33 minutes 25 minutes he's
got me on twitter you try to get the
time
soccer mom car
and then they forget about it but i'm
like obsessed with it like making right
now
shave two off shave two off that's
exactly what i'd say
uh no i mean
they but they're using their own
resources but i will say that there's
some things that we've lost which is
like what we're talking about like
physically setting up these cameras like
they know how to get in front of it and
create something but the rest of it is
what they don't know well also it's
interesting too because with especially
with the dating apps i feel like a lot
of people have lost i don't know about
human interaction yeah and how i can't
even know how to approach until like
imagine right now if you were a single
woman in this age and you're trying to
pick up people in all five look at you
you like that pasta sauce
i like rotiti curls too man you free
tonight
oh god i mean that's how i can't even
imagine i've been with my husband 21
years married 16. we joke around about
it because he's not on social media so
he always likes to threaten tease me
like i don't know i might get on there
he's like people are gonna start looking
me up from high school that likes me and
[ __ ] i'm like this you're okay
so we let it
but
but you know he says i feel like i'm
missing out sometimes because you're
saying all these jokes i'm like you're
not and you'll be on it all the time so
don't bother with it but
um yeah i don't know i mean i feel like
these kids with the social media and the
tick tock and the this and that it's
like but it's their time that's their
time it's so in your face the only thing
i will say
and this is like like what i was just
talking about is the bullying thing like
people are so shitty and mean to each
other and i think there is like a vibe
of you know we just went to the harry
styles concert like treat people with
kindness just be kind i do think it's
way cooler to be kind nowadays than to
not be like when i was younger i felt
like
maybe it was cooler than to be an
[ __ ] but ball buster
yeah but then now i feel like it's
gotten so far off the deep end and i
also feel
that pendulum has swung to people being
so sensitive everybody is so damned he
said i'm tall oh my god people won't
yeah let me tell you i'm curious what
they'll pick out of this interview but
people will pick stuff out
and we won't even know what it was about
what are they talking about you see the
way she moved that cup yeah
i mean that's that's the crazy thing
like she got almond nails she got almond
now
he's trying to live out my teenage year
no i mean that's that's the crazy thing
is like these kids are
living their lives in front of the lens
like we have this different perspective
where we have both of it so we know what
it was like before and we know what it's
like now so we can kind of make fun of
it we can kind of see it for what it is
but these kids now
this is all they know and it scares me
because my 11 year old you know what by
the time you get to the last kid you're
like are they still in the room yeah
like i got two i mean there's genuinely
been times where we're like oh [ __ ] did
we pick up so-and-so you know so
she's getting the most of it because
she's had a lot of down time in front of
an electronic even though we don't let
her have a phone yet and she's in middle
school i mean she will have a working
phone it's like she has to use it on
wi-fi or whatever she has access to see
all these things and
what beauty is what you know what
what's important what's not well she
makes videos with stella and stuff and i
love burritos
yeah i
that's a creative movie thing i love
that i love that but mia's over there
like doing the did you see the new
tick-tock dance mom is it just like this
one
like it's all the same
that's all they do all day like what is
that
i tried you know when i first did one i
thought that the way they look at the
camera i thought that
the like they showed you the dance and
you mimicked it as you went so she's
like okay let's let's do it and we went
in then i'm like how do you know what to
do she's like oh you have to like watch
the i'm like and memorize it
so i'll give them that they're they're
learning choreography but
i mean some of it's just like come on
and i don't like looking at it i don't
like looking at them getting older on
the
yeah you got you have to keep on them
but i try to look at it like look
they're creating content it's as long as
they have a good foundation of like
what is and who you are and like today
mia went to school and was all
worried that because she just got over
coveted yeah and she's cleared to go to
school that everybody was gonna treat
her like she had the plague
and it was cute because she's all
they're gonna treat me like i have the
plaque and i'm like the black i said i
mean we do have to go to the dentist
but no she said the plague and i was
like oh how sad does that happen she's
like yeah so-and-so came back and nobody
wanted to sit with them or
and i hadn't had a cup of coffee yet and
i was i was weak on my advice i was like
well
well then they're [ __ ]
yeah
you'll have some alone time at lunch i
mean hopefully she'll be cool but yeah
kids are mean girls are meaner than boys
for sure
but adults are mean and then it's as i
tell my kids i'm like it is no i
literally had a middle school experience
once i became city council
i mean people call me cussed me out for
votes and i remember i told this one
lady i was like if we were in a target
parking lot you'd be kissing that
pavement
she was like click
and then call me back that's what i love
about you i remember being on the phone
with you and you're with the dsw and
you're like hang on hang on a second
right [ __ ] stop leave me alone i will
[ __ ] you up see me outside yeah i'm just
trying these heels on ryan this [ __ ]
and i just she was mad because i was on
the phone on the phone here talking to
me and i said something back through i
was [ __ ] around she heard it i
figured she's like oh he's over there
oh yes i'm bringing my and sometimes i'm
not proud of those moments but i'm like
this is me take it or leave it i mean
but i think that's what more we need
more of real people in these positions
not the [ __ ] [ __ ] politics not
all that like bring a real person in
that goes hey if we got to do a [ __ ]
45 minute powerpoint presentation could
you could you bring it down to [ __ ]
one yeah
one displayed it takes you five minutes
to [ __ ] go over this please uh
because you'll be like ryan i'm still on
a three hour phone call i'm like
and now i know you make fifteen thousand
dollars i'd have been like
we go down we go at five
and our meetings end
on average between midnight and two in
the morning
and most of it is because of discussions
that have to happen in front of
everybody and
callers and stuff like that but most of
it is discussions that are happening on
the dice between there's new council
members like so not everybody there's
this is the first time there's been this
many women there's uh five of us out of
the seven
and this many newer
um like untraditional incumbents like so
these are it's four of us are really new
so
nobody gives you that's the other thing
so you get on city council and i'm like
okay when's the training they're like
you know they give you a training about
like basic things it's like sexual
harassment and now you're a public
figure so you can't do this and
no more than three of your council
members like we were at a restaurant the
other night and there was three of us
and one showed up and pulled up a seat
and somebody has to leave because really
yeah it's the brown act violation as
brown act
it's you can't have more than three
members out of the seven together in any
setting whether it be in case you off
the [ __ ] at the same time the brown act
because we gotta talk about some [ __ ]
so if we're talking about stuff that's
it's because all our meetings have to be
in public the public has to see what
you're discussing so you can't all just
three people's the max for a personal so
when you're talking to another counselor
you have to say is anyone in your brown
act before we discuss this agenda item
like you can't call up and talk about
all the items right and if you talk to
someone about the other it's all so
that's one thing that they train you on
but they don't tell you like how to put
a 13 item
like i put one to make tattoos illegal
in santa monica um they don't tell you
like the process to do things and
there's a couple people up there who've
been on there and it's intimidating with
the city attorney because they'll clown
you on live tv but i don't care because
i got a sense of humor so but it can
feel a little intimidating because
you'll be like excuse me like ah it's
not your time and you need it like this
is a discussion you know you can't put
that forward and you're like okay sorry
so you just kind of learn as you go
um like life like life you just learn as
you go and that's what i want the i want
everybody to see in the community like i
mean i wish they paid them more and
that's why these people that's why in
government you see this because you have
to do these
of service jobs to get to that point and
if you're a working class member unless
you're of society unless you're just
crazy like me
or you're really um you have a lot of
time on your hands and you can do it
like how could anyone give 30 to 40
hours a week and read 2 800 page agendas
every other week it's impossible and
meet with constituents i got people
coming to the music store the city
internet's out i'm like okay okay you're
on a ukulele right yeah um it's a lot
like to be expected to talk to everybody
and all that kind of stuff but i want
people to see that it is doable i mean
you can do it there's a woman on there
that has kids works from nine to five
and she just says i cannot call you back
until after five and she checks emails
and makes appointments on the weekends
and she makes it work for herself i mean
she's busy but
and me unfortunately i'm
making time for everybody well you've
look first of all you've done
wonderful things not only for you and
your family for the community you really
have for me like i love you you know i
do i really enjoy working here i really
enjoy
volunteering with both of the classes i
love it and i can't wait to learn i love
being a part of it and watching you
really make a difference in people's
lives it's awesome and thank you for
making time for me today
well thank you for having me yeah i love
that you'll come here to raise awareness
about this [ __ ] i'm about to raise
awareness about this ied
there there's the too much information
right there
i might be slipping out y'all
oh i'm just kidding
that'll be that'll make the headlines
that'll be our promo
um
one more time please plug ought to plug
it all please okay outreach through the
arts so the acronym is otta ott arts.org
tta
well ott arts which is
okay not farts okay
o-t-t-a-r-t-s
dot org
dot org and then santa monica music
center dot com
we'll take you to our website which
shows you both culver city and santa
monica i'm looking at the camera um
and you can see what we're doing at both
locations you could we've got all the
gear so you literally could just come in
record
take your sd card home um or you can
hire one of our engineers to cut it for
you so you're doing it right i love it
yeah i'm trying you're helping me i
realized listen if you're going sorry i
realize you don't have to spend a
million dollars to start one look if
you're local for real if you're local
southern california la culver city
whatever hit lineup rent the space if
you definitely if you want to do a
podcast you can rent it by the hour you
can rent it long term whatever come in
and do whatever you want or you can
be in there to talk about live stream
your own content you can teach we have
teachers teaching lessons virtually on
there you can also rent practice space
for you know for musicians out there and
then of course we do lessons we've got
the dj camps with dj hoppa we've got um
for adults too so we've got a lot going
on we have our new ensemble that's
starting so any adults out there looking
to play with other adults we have a
sunday ensemble that's starting in our
rock band hell yeah so we're just doing
it one foot in front of the other that's
it
i mean there's only two people in the
bad but
four feet tall
i love you thank you for real thank you
for coming on and doing all this
thank you for having me welcome anytime
vote for lana vote for lana nagaretti
santa monica city council uh as always
ryan sickler.com ryan sickler on all
social media we'll talk to you all next
week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you